ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo su
allora è un videogame che ho trovato su
steam perché c'è su steam
ma voi non avete idea iniziamo la
grafica di sta roba è così io posso
scegliere il personaggio chi cazzo è
questo e con questo ragazzo intendo che
se proprio sono attori che fanno di zio
accesa una verde dietro era previsto
notai lo premuto ma se sei un deficiente
e morto non ho premuto hicks in tempo io
ce l'ho fatta invece meglio se io sono
più prova di tesi sono cose che capitano
unico mini e rese più e non lo sai che
ri ma è molto che stiamo per terra che
cazzo tocchi il naso jato devo chiamare
cristina ma no ma con l'iphone ragazzi e
yo yo loro proprio non ho parole per
questo videogame vi giuro
sai bene ma chi cazzo è cristina bene ho
premuto il sì in tempo però qualcuno ha
ucciso mez
ecco hanno ucciso un uomo
e tutto quello che sai dire va bene
permesso come stanno attaccando tutti
fuori il problema per chiudere la porta
e se non lo faremo anche mi sembra di
comandare un lungo plastico ho premuto a
bravo bravo zio complimenti 666 chiudere
le porte progaming ci stanno facendo i
kiss bike premi la sua bici tutti quanti
ognuno per se portiamo la bici ognuno
per se ne fotte sega ma cosa fanno
stanno stuprando il ciclista casi a
premi
[Musica]
questo è un checkpoint perché mi ha
tirato un calcio nelle palle ho vomitato
qualcuno mi spieghi dove non lascia per
premia ripetute mezzi vai vera e non ci
ho fatto non ci credo ma cos'è ma che
cazzo a fare sono morti ahia grazie
basta che io devo forti altri amici mi
dispiace già fatta faccio fatta
cosa fai svenuto ma si poté sei giorni
fra te e mi piace ma non c'è chi se ne
fotte amiamo devi salvare la tua
donzella uomo premier mi han tirato una
vibrata in faccia premiamo ok scrivo
sono io mi sono salvato premuto chi
cazzo è questa cosa vuoi possiamo
parlare sei carina brava ma sei un cesso
in calo al problema dirgli sei carina si
sa bene se ne frega campo cessa di
essere un cesso oddio ho fatta dove vai
premi y ripetuta ma e sto facendo
sto facendo che cosa fa sto superando la
staccionata sono vivo hanno tentato di
uccidermi con un libro cosa cazzo stato
a scendere ma io no no no va bene va
bene andiamo avanti sono vivo sono sei
vivo per miracolo
pressing pc complimenti ci siamo ragazzi
siamo a casa di cristina è stato
difficile arrivare fin qua per carità di
dio
ecco line marchio la tua coinquilina
stata intanto lo sa cos'è sta roba brevi
b e anzi sticazzi potevi scegliere un po
più nota colpi di grazia
minchia stata nata questa non scopa
danni suvvia questo brava cristina
guerra con che non sa lance cosa fa
questa va beh questa è però un pugno che
almeno lei dei reds ci sta questa
ragazza mi sarei ugualmente l'inner
wheel ingrassando che il calcio farà dog
e nell'ex nome ai negozi che cialente
ok io devo coprirla mentre si fa la
doccia
qual è il problema tanto facciamo una
doccia si stanno solo uccidendo tutti
sei pazza non abbiamo tempo per questo
donne ragazzi donne donne sono così le
donne sono tutte così premi psi non per
guardare alla tua ragazza mentre fa la
doccia ma 67 aveva una katana naso dio
[Musica]
ma perché la mia scelta è tra oh merda o
cazzo o crepe o crepe dai vai vai vai
vai lurida [ __ ] non ce l'ho fatta
devo dire che mi prenderanno prima si no
non mi hanno preso a mano presso la tipa
dietro ma ammazzatevi tra di voi cosa
volete la meta vista si stavano
ammazzando entra di loro cosa vogliono
ho fatto stavolta ce l'ho fatta stavolta
ci siamo ho fallito con la caccia è
questa
però ma questa era posto tirato un pugno
na civile a caso va bene tratti in un
problema non è che cos'è questo posto è
perché è la madonna cos'è the walking
dead premier a premi che ha più tasti
non mi dire che mi hai attaccato le
palle cena attaccato le palle
non sto pensando per terra lo pinzato a
terra ragazze impugnasse in faccia
eccolo lì perfetto questo sembrava vero
che schizza ancora molto ai pezzi
c'è uno zombie cos'è vabbè io non ho
capito se sono zombie o se dovrebbero
essere zombie però è la mado è questo ma
è l'unica che recita abbastanza bene
credo
vabbè mi dice di star lontano siamo
lontani ma la zona risultato sto
cristiano al cos'è premix ci siamo
ragazzi problemi di progaming cristina
dove cristina chi d'avena temi bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye passaggi a
mamma mia
quello ancora lì oddio sì
già fatta ce l'ho fatta non soltanto
abituato a utilizzare joystick dell'xbox
ma cosa cazzo sta succeda che è il
problema non è quello con la mazza da
hockey il problema è che sto sanguinando
e non sono stato io
io voglio capire i ragazzi che hanno
fatto sto gioco massi sono veramente
divertiti a registrarlo perché veramente
la tortura
cosa sta facendo
god of war che mi questo videogame ti
prego si stanno facendo
ma cos'è memo è morto è in sé stessa
l'etf finisco la scopa me lo guardava
inviare in alcuno hai trovato la chiave
grazie a dio meno male perché stavo per
scopare un uomo nel senso con la scopa
proprio quando stoppa non l'immagine
perché devo rispondere stoppano sempre
con delle espressioni meravigliosa chi
sei tu che cosa sta succedendo
ti piace la cioccolata ti piace la
cioccolata e la domanda che vorrei fare
ti piace la cioccolata brava o mio dio
ed anche le armi sei serio ma come e
cosa puoi scegliere allora mazza da
baseball
la motosega o la spada palloncino io
direi la spalla palloncino voglio vedere
che cazzo ne esce fuori at6 incazza ok
spiegami perchè c'è una spada a
palloncino sul tavolo voglio capirlo
devi spiegarmelo motosega castro dire
non ci avrà l'olio sicuro sei
soddisfatta dalla mia scelta ma l'ho
lasciata lei ragazzi abbiamo una
macchina incredibilmente solo che noi ma
io devo guidare con joystick o mio dio
sembra corretto rank che cazzo è a ciò
la motosega
solo che nel frank ce l'aveva lui la
motosega ragazzi faccio veramente cagare
a schivare le cose ma è una cosa
tristissima bravo questa è una mossa per
mettere ko l'uomo lanciargli una forza
dove lanciati una borsa potresti morire
non si è fatto un cazzo ragazzo è un
problema questo stavolta l'ho fatto
l'abbiamo fatta
ma con la motosega
[Musica]
[Applauso]
il vero problema è che la motosega non è
accesa come sta facendo
cosa sta facendo
io non lo so lo so non lo so non so
veramente non ne ho idea
a infilare la chiave ma questa volta
voglio vedere niente annuncia possiamo
far che il fantastico
infatti qui da ragazzi potrà guidare una
macchina vera per la prima volta nella
mia vita visto che non ho la patente ma
io che ho la macchina è comunque ragazzi
importante essere partiti in macchina
poi fotte sega possono mai stato così
tanto soddisfatto del finale di un
videogame un applauso meraviglioso
voglio sapere chi ha fatto star one e
giuro non ho parole
non vorrei fare tanti commenti ma non
posso perché c'è troppo a merda è nono
non so ditemi la vostra per me comunque
sia il ciclista un pezzo di merda
comunque sia ragazzi conclude episodio
cose tu sei vite risultato momento non
mi piace anche la pace di facebook con
invio trattare schizzare city sia facili
da un prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]
cala traglia costi riflessi del cazzo
che ciò city 16v da un prossimo video
della ragazza questa volta di culo